il est des circonstances comme celles
d'aujourd'hui où les responsables
politiques n'ont qu'un seul devoir
défendre la france est protégé les
français
les événements nous rappellent que nous
sommes au service d'une cause qui nous
dépasse tous une certaine idée de la
france
une certaine idée de la civilisation une
certaine idée de la liberté une certaine
idée de la façon d'être un homme
parce que c'est bien de cela dont la
france parle depuis si longtemps
c'est cette voix françaises que les
assassins veulent faire taire cette
jeunesse foudroyé au fond elle a donné à
la france son plus beau visage
le visage fraternel que les assassins
veulent des figures et en semant la peur
et la haine
nous ne cesserons pas d'être vulnérable
aux terribles désordre du monde
si nous leur posons que des pouvoirs de
police et des pompes
nous devons être capable de leur poser
aussi une unité une grille ions une
solidarité fondée sur une espérance
commune fondée j'ose le mot sur une
fierté partagée d'être les citoyens d'un
grand pays qu'a rendu de grands services
à l'humanité dans ce moment de doute
dans ce moment d'angoissé une seule idée
doit nous guider rendre aux français
quelles que soient leurs croyances
quelles que soient leurs origines
quelles que soient leurs histoires
personnelles leur rendent la france de
toujours que nous n'acceptons pas de
voir disparaître la france de toujours
dans mon esprit elle n'est pas immuable
la france de toujours qui n'est pas
immobile qui vit qui change qui
s'enrichit de tout ce qu'on lui donne
les valeurs de la france de toujours
c'est ce que nous avons de mieux à
offrir à nos enfants et à ceux qui
veulent partager notre destin